a Northern California woman is
recovering after falling 60 feet from a
730 foot bridge
officials say the unidentified woman
slipped while trying to take a selfie on
the forest Hill bridge in North O'Byrne
California the accidents putting a new
focus on the potential dangers posed by
posing for that perfect shot
Mireya Villarreal has the story it's one
of the tallest bridges in the country
and for some one of the biggest photo
ops whether it's a jaw-dropping movie
stunt a thrill-seeking online video or a
heart-stopping picture but officials say
earlier this week an attempt at being
picture-perfect almost turned deadly
Tuesday an unidentified woman and her
friends were walking on a beam
underneath the catwalk of the seven
hundred and thirty foot forest hill
bridge she was trying to take a selfie
when she lost her footing and fell 60
feet landing on a trail below her friend
saw it all happen
first responders took the woman by
stretcher and airlifted her to a local
hospital I think it has a lot to do with
the shock and awe of social media Masur
county sheriff's lieutenant Troy Sanders
says despite warning signs and security
gates Daredevils still find their photo
op by doing so you really compromise
your own safety and that of the people
around you and potentially the first
responders have to come down here and
deal with it since 2015 the Sheriff's
Department has issued dozens of
citations and says it sees more selfie
takers on the bridge as the weather gets
warm possibly encouraged by other photos
they see on social media as for this
latest incident officials decided not to
charge the woman involved
we felt the impact of what they saw and
what they went through based on her
accident was enough to really drive home
a message that it's not a good idea and
you can potentially die for CBS this
morning Saturday media via Los Angeles
the woman apparently is still in the
hospital we don't know what kind of
condition she's in but we hope we hope
she recovers but we hope that people
stop taking
selfies on catwalks above cats you
couldn't even get me to go out on that
catwalk little on tickets people used to
ask someone a stranger can you take a
photo of me let's get back to that it
arrived you know what I mean the same
course no one will go out there with you
on well there's that